bonjour à tous ces paléo news l'émission
qui fait des news avec du vieux
aujourd'hui une émission spéciale
consacrée au japon la géologie du pays
du soleil levant est surtout connu pour
ses volcans et ses tremblements de terre
mais beaucoup moins pour ces fossiles
mais les japonais sont comme de tous
fascinés par les monstres du passé et
les chercheurs ils sont très actifs
comme en nouvelle zélande en australie
et sur les maurice l'histoire de la vie
sur les îles nippone après quelques
détours particulier du fait de leur
isolement
et si sur ces autres ils sont apparus
des espèces dont les plus proches
parents continentaux se sont éteints il
y a des dizaines voire des centaines de
millions d'années alors imaginer quelles
surprises attendent les curieux dans le
sous sol japonais
cet épisode hors série vous propose de
découvrir ce patrimoine méconnu
on commence par la découverte d'un
nouveau mozart au japon ce pays libre
depuis la fin du 19e siècle
d'impressionnants fossiles de reptiles
marins mésozoïque tels que des tortues
des plésiosaures ou ce magnifique
nouveau mozart phosphore au russe vient
du crétacé de l'île d'hokkaido la plus
au nord du japon
il a la particularité de posséder de
très grande ouverture pour les yeux
ainsi qu'une vision binoculaire
ces deux caractéristiques augmenterait
le nombre de cellules photosensibles
capable de capter la lumière dans le
champ de vision ce qui suggère que ce
petit mozart était nocturne et chasser
la nuit alors que les grands spécimens
de mozac zaurus le chassait le jour
cette découverte illustre la complexité
de l'écosystème marin japonais au
crétacé toujours du côté des reptiles
mésozoïque voici fukui venator un petit
dinosaure d'une vingtaine de kilos
provenant du crétacé du japon très
similaire au drôme et aux autorités du
continent fukui venator possède un douar
repliable vers le haut sur le pied qui
rappelle beaucoup la griffe des célèbres
raptor néanmoins fukui venator semble
plus primitifs pour le reste de son
squelette et possède plusieurs
caractères qu'on ne retrouve pas chez
les drom et aux au rider comme la
présence de très grosses narines est
d'une dentition très spécialisés à
l'avant de la mâchoire les dents sont
robustes et spatules et tandis qu'elles
sont coupante et recourbées au milieu et
de taille réduite à l'arrière
cette différenciation dentaire semble
indiquer un régime omnivore rare dans la
famille des théropodes et souligne la
mosaïque de caractère très spécialisés
qui rendent la classification de fukui
venator dans un groupe particulier de
théropodes difficile cela montre à quel
point la prise en compte du registre
fossile japonais est importante
une bonne compréhension de l'évolution
des dinosaures on reste parmi les
dinosaures avec la découverte du côté de
tokyo le 3 juillet 2016 d'une dent de
titanosaures reform vieille de 130
millions d'années et trouvé par un jeune
garçon de 14 ans alors qu'un dinosaure
aussi unique que fukui venator souligner
la particularité des faunes dinosaures
viennent du japon les titanosaures
reform eux sont très communs en asie en
chine en mongolie et en russie par
exemple
cette découverte suite annoncé quasiment
un an jour pour jour après celle près de
nagasaki d'une dent de 8 cm de long est
vieille de 80 millions d'années ayant
appartenu à un représentant de la
famille des tyrannosaures aux ide
oui les tyrannosaures aux ide ont bel et
bien un jour hanter le sol du japon les
tyrannosaures aux ide sont très communs
en asie particulièrement en mongolie où
le célèbre tarbes odos russe bata
pendant asiatique du tyrannosaurus rex
dominer la chaîne alimentaire
ces deux découvertes rappelle que le
japon faisait autrefois partie du
continent asiatique
à l'époque des dinosaures et qu'il le
sens des achats que bien des dizaines de
millions d'années plus tard
étant donnée sa significativité
scientifique la découverte du jeune
garçon est exposé au musée de tokushima
depuis le 3 septembre à l'ombre des
dinosaures maintenant intéressons nous
aux mammifères du crétacé le japon est
très connu pour ces mammifères
mésozoïque tels que soliste s sayama
milos ou encore à kusano bâtard tous
très proches des espèces qu'on rencontre
en chine et en mongolie à la même époque
néanmoins la découverte de pas moins de
250 dans ayant appartenu à une nouvelle
espèce de thérapie site prémat malien
treaty l'odon idée fait sa particularité
d'être utile aux dons idées sont
considérés comme les derniers terap site
prémat maliens ayant survécu durant le
mésozoïque on pensait qu'il s'était état
à la fin du jurassique mais la
découverte de ses dents dans le crétacé
du japon indique qu'ils ont pu survivre
là 30 millions d'années supplémentaires
soit la moitié du temps qui nous sépare
du dernier t-rex cette trouvaille
suggère que malgré le fait qu'il était
reliée au continent le japon devait déjà
servir de refuge pour certains groupes
d'animaux à l'instar de l'australie pour
ces mots notres m
et ces marsupiaux qui tombe maintenant
le mésozoïque et intéressons-nous aux
mammifères du cénozoïque et notamment
ceux qui sont parmi les plus étranges
ayant occupé le japon les desnos chilien
les 10 most îliens sont des mammifères
aux allures d'hippopotames ayant vécu
entre 30 et 7 millions d'années ils ont
la particularité d'avoir des dents fait
de barils d'émail juxtaposés sept
familles d'animaux amphibie aînés
c'est diversifié le long des côtes de
l'océan pacifique uniquement ce qui
explique que vous n'en ayez peut-être
jamais entendu parler avant
de par leur anatomie sans commune mesure
les 10 most îliens ont toujours été très
dur à classer mais un consensus s'était
établi pour en faire des cousins des
éléphants des lamantins et des arts
signataires tous africains ceux ci
n'allait pas sans poser de problèmes
comment diable les desnos chilien serait
il arrivé dans le pacifique depuis
l'afrique sans ne laisser aucune trace
fossiles en chemin la réponse vient de
tomber comme une évidence aux yeux de la
communauté scientifique les 10 most
îliens ne serait tout simplement pas
proche des éléphants mais du groupe des
chevaux et des rhinocéros qu'on appelle
les persos dactyle à l'appui de cette
hypothèse on retrouve le fait que les
périodes acte ils étaient très répandues
à cette époque en asie et en amérique
c'est à dire autour du pacifique et
qu'un groupe de mammifères nommer les
emprunts comme une idée originaire
d'inde est aussi semi-aquatique semble
faire office d'intermédiaire entre
l'épée risso dactyle bazzo et les 10
most îliens si cela s'avère exact
voilà qui retirera un épineux problème
biogéographique du pied des
paléontologues
terminons enfin avec les proboscidiens
le saviez vous mais il ya eu des
éléphants au japon le japon tel que nous
le connaissons aujourd'hui a commencé à
se séparer du continent entre 25 et 17
millions d'années quand la mer du japon
s'est formé les îles ce peuple alors de
rhinocéros et d'autres espèces
d'étranges comme les calicots terre
sorte de chevaux munis de l'ombre à
terminer par des glyphes au lieu de
sabots leur donnant des allures de paris
ce géant s'y installe aussi des abeilles
géantes qui montre les affinités centre
et sud-est asiatique de cette faune et
de cette flore mais en réexaminant leur
collection de fossiles les
paléontologues japonais se sont rendus
compte qu'une espèce parmi elle se
démarquait nettement le steagall aux
photos ce dernier après avoir évolué
pendant plusieurs millions d'années sur
le jeune archipel est devenu de plus en
plus petit tant et si bien qu'il y à 16
millions d'années il est devenu nains
les cas de nanisme dit insulaire suite à
l'adaptation à la vie isolé sur une île
ne sont pas rares chez les éléphants
il en existe en effet de nombreux
exemples autour de la méditerranée mais
aucun n'a atteint l'âge canonique de 16
millions d'années ainsi le steagall aux
faux don japonais est le plus vieux qu'à
de nanisme insulaire documenté chez un
mammifère jusqu'à ce jour et il démontre
qu'il y à 16 millions d'années l'
isolement des faunes japonaise par la
mer était déjà particulièrement
prononcée on parle d'endémisme des fon
insulaire la curiosité de l'émission
c'est provence
i roto tease giganteus à représentant
xxl de la famille des céphalopodes
vampire au mof découvert en 1998 au
japon les vampires au mof forme d'une
étrange et ancienne famille de
mollusques céphalopodes dont le curieux
calamars vampire est aujourd'hui le
dernier représentant ses ventouses en
forme de pointe sa couleur rouge vif et
le fait qu'ils soient bio luminescents
ont valu à ce qu'à la mare le nom
terrifiant de vampires otis infernal
hills rien que cela
néanmoins ne vous inquiétez pas pour vos
baignades car malgré son nom terrifiant
vampire auto this ne se nourrit que de
plancton la véritable curiosité n'est
pas temps de découvrir des vampires
morse fossiles dans les couches daté du
crétacé mais de les avoir découverts
dans le thorax d'un autre animal entre
les côtes d'un plésiosaure découvert au
japon
le calamar vampire semble avoir fait
l'objet du dernier repas du reptile
marin ne restait des pauvre céphalopode
que leur bec
la seule partie suffisamment dur pour
être préservée dans la roche le nom
giganteus de ce vampire auto this vient
des dimensions de ce bec
inhabituellement grand par rapport à l'
espèce de calamar vampire actuelle le
registre fossile nippon est néanmoins
coutumier de la découverte de kraken
fossiles puisqu'on y découvre aussi liée
d auto tease giganteus abrutissent
poséidon ou bien encore nani moto this i
qui dailly des palais au céphalopode
géant aux mensurations comparable à
celle d'art qui tissent le calamar géant
actuel pour la rubrique vintage nous
revenons en 1998 quand une mise au point
sur l'évolution des éléphants fossiles
du japon a permis de comprendre
l'histoire du peuplement animal de ce
pays comme nous l'avons déjà dit le
japon ne s'est isolé du continent qui
lie à 16 millions d'années quand les
mouvements tectoniques ont fait se
soulever les îles et ça paie c'est le
socle de la mer du japon qui le sépare
du continent
des espèces comme le steagall aux
fraudes on se sont alors retrouvés là
isolés et ont commencé à évoluer en
parallèle de leurs cousins continentaux
pourtant quand on regarde le peuplement
actuelle désigne iphone on constate
qu'il n'est pas si différent que cela de
celui du continent l'île d'hokkaïdo est
peuplé par des animaux commun avec
l'hémisphère nord comme lou ce bras
tandis que les îles du sud dont l'île
principale de honshu sont peuplées par
des espèces de la faune est et centre
asiatique comme l'ours noir du tibet
c'est aussi dans ces îles du sud qu'on
rencontre des espèces dites endémique
c'est à dire typique du japon comme les
célèbres macaques à face rouge ou
macaques des neiges
et les écureuils volants du japon ces
espèces endémiques n'existe pas sur
hokkaido
cela a donc amené les biologistes à
penser que le détroit de tsugaru qui
sépare les deux il a agit comme une
barrière entre le nord et le sud les
îles du sud auraient vu leur faune
immigrés depuis la corée il ya très
longtemps tandis que hokkaido aurait vu
sa faune immigrés depuis la sibérie via
l'île de sakhaline plus récemment
peut-être durant le dernier âge
glaciaire scénario intéressant oui mais
où étaient les preuves et quelles
étaient les dates exactes
les réponses à ces questions ont été
superbement fournies par le registre
fossile des proboscidiens nippon les
paléontologues conjointement avec les
biologistes ont en effet démontré dans
une série d'articles parus entre 1998 et
2000 que plusieurs vagues d'immigration
ont eu lieu entre le japon et le
continent durant les dix derniers
millions d'années
les vagues de migration les plus
anciennes ont vu débarquer sur les îles
nippone plusieurs espèces d'éléphants
venus de chine tels que sting au don et
paléo l'oxo dont soit pas moins de sept
espèces en tout c'est l'immigration
ancien des ancêtres des espèces
endémiques qui peuplent aujourd'hui on
joue la plupart d'entre elles sont
arrivés il y en a entre 5 et 1.5
millions d'années puis zilli à cent
mille ans l'ère glaciaire change
complètement la donne les glaces et la
baisse du niveau de la mer forme d'un
passage continu entre la sibérie
sakhaline et hokkaido
c'est le débarquement de la faune
typique de la steppe à mahmoud
sibérienne et rien ne peut sembler
aujourd'hui - japonais que cette liste
d'animaux jugez par vous même des
mammouths laineux mais aussi des bisons
des chevaux des cerfs et bien sûr des
ours bruns on ne retrouve ses éléments
de faune cas hokkaido
mais pas au sud en dessous s'est donc
retrouvé complètement isolée par deux
des trois celui de la corée et celui de
tsugaru et on sait aujourd'hui que c'est
détroit sont profonds de 130 mètres
tandis que durant le maximum glaciaire
la mère n'a régressé que de 100 à 120
mètres dans cette partie du globe
cela a suffi pour que la faune sud
nippone soit laissée livrée à elle-même
et commence à voir évoluer son propre
lot d'espèces si particulière depuis
lors certaines espèces se sont éteintes
d'autres franchi le détroit de tsugaru
mais dans les grandes lignes la faune de
l'archipel japonaise est directement
hérité de ces grands événements de
migration d'abord depuis le sud puis
depuis le nord durant l'ère glaciaire
alors que le sud était encore isolées
ainsi le registre fossile des
proboscidiens est un at il confirmé et
précisé
modèle de peuplement établi par
l'observation des seules espèces
actuelles le coup de coeur de cette
émission c'est la classification du
gisement de fukui angers au parc par
l'unesco en 2009 découvert en 1989 le
site de fukui a durant ces vingt
dernières années d'exploitation livrer
les restes d'une dizaine d'espèces de
dinosaures des eaux mais aussi des oeufs
et des empreintes ainsi que
d'innombrables tortues crocodiles
mammifères et autres vertébrés
terrestres du crétacé cette faune qui
partage beaucoup de similitudes avec
celle de mongolie montre que le japon
était rattaché au continent à l'époque
du règne des dinosaures on retrouve au
japon les grands carnivores
tyrannosaures aux ide comme sur le
continent ainsi que l'allosaure aux ide
fukui raptor mais aussi les étrangetés
résine autorités ont des terres aussi
des herbivores géants sauropodes tels
que fukui titans et tamba titane hisse
ainsi que des no 2 or caparaçonnés des
ornithologues à bec de canard comme
fukui taurus et cochons iso russe et le
cera pod alba lofo zaurus un proche
parent des cératopsidés les oeufs de
dinosaures indique qu'à cette liste
devait s'ajouter des troodontidés et d
ovi rap torride et tandis que les
centaines d'empreintes de pas recensé
attestent de la présence de nombreux
hétéros szohr la création du géoparc a
suivi de près l'inauguration du musée
préfecture al de fukui le 14 juillet
2000 construit près du site de fukui qui
a donné son nom à tant de dinosaures
japonais il s'agit du troisième plus
grand musée du monde consacré
exclusivement aux dinosaures
après le musée royal tyrone au canada et
le musée de zhigang en chine l'invité de
cette émission c'est jean-michel
abrassart docteur de psychologie
professeur de japonais est passionné par
la philosophie et la culture du japon
avec qui nous avons eu une discussion
autour des folklores biais aux fossiles
alors ce qui surprend au premier abord
c'est là la difficulté avec laquelle on
peut trouver des informations sur les
fossiles japonais sur la paléontologie
japonaise et d'après d'après les
recherches que j'ai fait en gros c'est
un il ya une grosse raisons historiques
à ça c'est qu'en fait contrairement à la
chine voisine en fête ou à d'autres pays
du sud est et du sud est asiatique le
japon à une pharmacopée traditionnelle
qui est relativement pauvre en possible
par exemple en chine on retrouve les
fameux longue ou qu'ils sont
donc ce qui signifie hausse de dragons
et qui sont très couramment utilisé dans
la pharmacopée qu'ils sont et les
gisements sont connus et exploité depuis
longtemps il ya vraiment un profond
enracinement historique de la géologie
en chine mais au japon l'enracinement
historique de la géologie commence
réellement qu'à l'ère meiji c'est ce qui
est aux alentours de 1850 à peu près
laquelle les premiers géologue qui sont
tous occidentaux d'ailleurs qui arrive
au japon
petite anecdote là dessus c'est que
l'une des premières cartes géologiques
du japon est en français parce que c'est
un français qui a ils ont cartographié
hokkaido est donc la preuve l'une des
premières cartes géologiques du japon
c'est hokkaido et elle est légendée en
français la géologie malherbe beaucoup
moins ancrée historiquement il ya
quelques rares exemples qu'on a réussi à
trouver avec jean-michel parmi ces
exemples il ya les griffes de tengu qui
servait à guérir les possessions par les
démons et ses griffes de tongs ou en
fait c'étaient des fossiles de requins
dont il y avait un peu de tout les
requins y aller les grands des fossiles
de grands requins blancs de 2,5 millions
d'années qui était pris pour des griffes
donc de certaines goût et il ya même des
alors ce qu'on avait lu dans un article
qui il y avait un titre très amusant
d'ailleurs c'était biologie of the
darkside la géologie du côté obscur et
il y avait cette référence aux dents du
requin géant megalodon et qui était
considérée comme les griffes du roi
dating où tu peux nous parler des
détails ngou et de qu'on peut prendre
une dent de requin pour une griffe de
chengdu pour l'aspect geste historique
at il mentionné avec la avec la fête que
la géologie etc
il est arrivé à l'ère meiji au japon il
faut pas oublier qu'avant l'ère meiji ou
d'un point de vue historique le japon
est fermé à l'occident no kill ans les
seuls occidentaux qui sont autorisés à
aller au japon sont les hollandais qui
ont un petit port d'attache à nagasaki
qui est très très loin de la capitale
est donc évidemment comme le japon n'a
pas de contact avec l'occident
ça a un impact sur son
sur sa capacité à accéder au savoir
qu'ils sont développés de par chez nous
forcément oui il ya eu ce qu'on appelle
les études hollandaise donc c'est à dire
qu'évidemment comme les hollandais
étaient à nagasaki il emmenait des
livres avec eux les intellectuels
traduisait du hollandais vers le
japonais et puis comme il pouvait quoi
et alors donc il y avait quand même un
certain accès mais c'était quand même un
tout petit canal d'information et donc
forcément quand quand le jeu le japon
est ouvert pour le colonel péri vers
1850 comme tu l'as bien précise et donc
à ce moment là pour les alliés il ya eu
un processus et puis l'ère meiji est
arrivé vers 1860 donc à une réforme du
gouvernement etc et le japon ont
commencé à se moderniser très très fort
et qu'est ce qu'ils font pour se
moderniser très très fort c'est pour
apprendre et apprendre les sciences
occidentales et la philosophie et donc
ils envoient des hordes de jeunes
japonais étudier dans les universités
européennes et donc c'est assez logique
toutes les disciplines à l'occidentale
arrive à ce moment là chez eux donc
toutes les sciences la plupart des
disciplines la philo la géologie et ses
vents comme à l'occidentale vont
commencer à ce moment là au japon ça
c'était pour la petite natte history
letting go bas juste pour faire ya un
pas en arrière
les créatures dont on va parler ça
s'appelle des yôkai et donc c'est des
monstres folklorique japonais et donc le
japon a un immense folklore qui est
largement inconnu chez nous avec le
bémol qu'évidemment il s'exporte chez
nous par les anime et maintenant et donc
que la jeune génération commence à en
avoir une idée à travers les animer bon
évidemment c'est une source un peu en
direct à les animer c'est pas non plus
un cours de folklore japonais m'enfin
y'a des choses qui apparaissent dans les
animés et donc ce folklore extrêmement
riche et énormément de créatures et donc
le tango est l'une de ces créatures et
ça c'est une créature du folklore chine
toi donc le chine tourisme c'est la
religion natif du japon donc on peut le
voir comme un avocat est donc une
créature féerique où 1 1 camille donc un
dieu de la crise de la religion shinto
essais des créatures qui sont qui
originellement été un peu aviaire elle
était une c'était des oiseaux un peu une
manière rythmée donc elle avait un tech
et puis avec le temps
ça a évolué et maintenant la
représentation classique à l'heure
actuelle du tango c'est un humanoïde
mais avec un très très long nez et donc
si les spectateurs
enfin les auditeurs sont intéressés on
voit on voit des tengu dans par exemple
le dernier fifa
le film les 47 ronald à la version avec
keanu reeves il ya des tengu qui
apparaissent un petit look un peu un peu
mieux moumni oiseaux voilà mais enfin
encore une fois l'apparence actuelle du
monstre c'est quelqu'un avec un très
très long on est certains y voient un
peu une forme phallique justement alors
après comment ça se fait que détendre
qu'un amphithéâtre
à l'heure actuelle en tout cas c'est pas
pas immédiats pour enfin en tout cas
pour moi ce n'est pas flagrant pourquoi
des dents trois éminentes seraient des
dancing ou même je suppose qu'à l'époque
ça avait 10 ans quand même des griffes
du coup bah oui mais que tu l'aimés tu
sais puisque tu le décris comme des
oiseaux ouais ça peut être les tisseyre
ans exactement je n'ai pas du tout pensé
me tutoie tout à fait avoir raison de ce
côté là j'avais vu que les images
justement tu parlais des formes
humanoïdes j'ai jamais vu la forme ou
oiseaux des techniques donc c'est pour
ça que ça m'avait pas sauté aux
industries effectivement si si au départ
ils étaient représentés comme des
oiseaux effectivement ça peut être les
amis ce mystère résolu en live voilà
alors dans les autres créatures dont on
a parlé il y avait le kappa tout cela
c'est vraiment des grands classiques 1
dans les uk le cap à 7,1 êtres
humanoïdes hommes poissons qui a comme
différentes caractéristiques donc il vit
dans les rivières il est alors il a une
sorte d'assiette sur le sommet du crâne
qui remplit d'eau et on dit généralement
que si on en rencontre un ils sont assez
agressif il faut leur faire la courbette
est alors la courbette japonaise le
salut japonais puissent ils font la
courbette en feront la courbette en
retour parce qu'ils sont très polis et
alors l'eau qui est dans leur assiette
sur leur tête face écoulée et à ce
moment là ils perdront leur pouvoir leur
force
ça c'est encore une version très
surnaturel originellement le cap a été
présenté comme extrêmement dangereux
donc on associe un peu quel pays aux
autres créatures d eau qu que les
parents que la famille utilise pour dire
aux enfants
n'approchez pas de la rivière il ya des
cas pas dans la rivière c'est une mise
en garde
par rapport aux aux étangs du taux
maintenant le cas pas avec au xxème
siècle dans les animés c'est vraiment
devenu très mignon un peu comme le
monstre du loch ness sur vers le cnes en
ad on a droit des peluches super
mignonne mais maintenant le cap a
souvent présenté dans les dessins animés
comme comme comme une petite créature
dévoila humanoïdes mais pas du tout
agressive que ceux présentés de manière
très mignonne encore une fois dans les
représentations de les ré d'eau on a des
dessins assez assez assez fun de
personnes en train de faire leurs
besoins dans une rivière et alors le cap
pas les attaques par l'arrière train
pour essayer d'extraire le leurs organes
par l'arrière train part c'est toujours
marrant quand on voit ces
représentations la classique entre
guillemets puis qu'on voit les versions
mignonne à l'heure actuelle qu'on
présente aux enfants si on en parle
c'est parce qu'il ya des cas des momies
de capa qu'on peut trouver quand j'étais
encore une fois au japon j'avais eu
l'occasion de visiter une exposition sur
les cryptides japonais à l'époque donc
un peu les toutes les créatures qu'on
est en train de parler
l'exposition était dans un musée
d'histoire japonais et tous été
présentés de manière totalement factuel
exacte tout les prêts entre les
créatures étaient présentés comme
existantes c'est incroyable c'est comme
s'ils avaient une exposition où on
disait que le loch ness est réelle le
bigfoot est réel enfin il veut
absolument aucune distance critique par
rapport à rien et donc il parlait de ces
créatures et il y avait présenté comme
un peu le clou de la traction une momie
de capa et y avait aussi deux momies de
cire l on entendait encore après c'était
ces deux mamies et c'était assez marrant
haut niveau parce que justement je me
pose beaucoup de questions au niveau de
la croyance des gens par rapport à ces
entités inscrites mais c'est vrai que
c'était incroyable quand je me tenais à
devant la momie de kappa et j'entendais
les visiteurs qui passait qui disait ah
mais les visiteurs japonais évidemment
qu'ils disent elles allaient les caps
combes racontait dans mon enfance était
vrai alors il ya vraiment des caps à
bangkok
beaucoup ont été surpris et un peu
choqués mais du coup la présence de la
momie était une sorte de confirmation
empirique pour les tout venant qui
venait dans le musée que les capa avait
une existence physique et encore une
fois ce genre de choses pourraient leur
être confirmée dans dans les
documentaires qui passent à la tv
japonaise du type c'est un peu comme à
l'édile et les documentaires qui passe
chez nous sur les extraterrestres ont
construit les pyramides
il y en a régulièrement qui montrent des
gens à la recherche de cas pas dans
l'accord va les choses comme ça quoi
c'est tellement c'est des limites qui
sont du folklore qui est tellement
ancrée dans la culture japonaise
il y va comme tu dit avoir souvent
soupçon de doute peut-être que ça existe
pour devrait finalement en quoi qu'en
fait ces momies sont en fait des momies
qui sont conservés dans des sanctuaires
d'al et sanctuaire shintoïste ou des
temples bouddhistes
donc normalement ils sont inaccessibles
à la vue à l'arrière du temps qu'on peut
pas y accéder et dans cet arrière de
temps qu'il ya des objets magiques qui
elle est interdit au grand public où il
ya des objets qu'on ne peut pas
contempler la plupart du temps sauf
quand il ya un festival ou des choses
comme ça ça c'est assez similaire à chez
nous le le sang de saint janvier ou le
prépuce de jésus au tout les choses
qu'on trouve dans les églises
et il ya ces momies elles font partie de
tout ça puisque bon voilà comme je les
dis ces créatures sont entre les dieux
les cryptides enfin c'est un peu parfois
les mots me sont sortis ces sanctuaires
pour des expositions exceptionnelles
on nous permettent au grand public de
les voir alors évidemment c'est
exactement comme pour les reliques de
jésus dont le bois du de la croix etc
laisse les temples shintoïstes ne laisse
pas examinée par des scientifiques
cesser ces reliques religieuses un hymne
à une les scientifiques n'ont pas accès
pour faire des tests ou les examiner de
plus près mais le consensus général
c'est que il s'agit en fait surtout par
exemple le problème pour les sirènes de
momies qui sont créés en mettant une
tête de singe c'est un japonais avec une
accord de poids sont donc allés à
l'aller redo il y avait des sorts de
carnaval qui exposait des bizarres tait
et on exposait ce type de mobile pour la
population il semblerait qu'il y ait
tout un commerce qui s'est développée
c'est à dire qu'il ya certains villages
de pêcheurs qui sont devenus des
spécialistes de la fabrication de deux
momies de sirènes et de momi cap acquis
et qu'il vendait à ces carnavals le fait
que l'animal et momifié
lui donne une apparence absolument
bizarre et étrange et ya rien de plus
effrayant qu'une momie de singe c'est un
aspect humanoïde à moitié mort c'est dur
de garder les yeux dessus
donc effectivement je peux comprendre
que ça impressionne ça ça fait penser
aux histoires de confusion on dit kaka
bra avec des animaux qui ont qui ont
perdu leurs poils etc
c'est juste des animaux qui sont dans un
contexte inhabituel
là en plus il ya eu un travail artisanal
qui était réalisé dessus pour pour
associer des parties d'animaux
différentes
du coup voilà c'est clair qu à les
réseaux c'est clair que ça te faire
sensation et les gens ils croyaient
certainement pour de vrai là encore dans
le musée où j'étais l'exposition où
j'étais le japonais lors da qui voyait
ça a été quand même un peu en état de
choc ou et découvrir ça ça lui
paraissait extrêmement fins par
extrêmement crédit mais en tout cas
c'était impressionnant en quoi
suffisamment impressionnant pour mettre
le doute dans son esprit que le kappa
n'est pas née anna paquin animal
totalement imaginaire pour en savoir
plus vous pouvez retrouver jean michel
sur son balade au scepticisme
scientifique
c'était paléo news merci de l'avoir
suivi toutes les infos et les liens vers
les actus sont dans la description
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens à très bientôt